[Music]
[Applause]
this was last Monday morning her life
[Music]
mind you it's not it's not what the
conversation I'll make that investment
to get you a full time camera guy
because you're right you have doesn't
right thing D rocks literally right
behind me right now so I'm saying it a
little louder and he's gonna start
betting okay give some thought give me a
final three
all right I'll make I'll make out and
you're yet by the way by the way if
you're an Afghanistan I'm making you
investment I'm trying to get next to you
I tried playing like you don't matter
but deep down I got
and since it's so shy
we can't blame me I've got that's a good
excuse
to say
I love coconuts
super live wish I could juggle you can
you juggle well no this is - you got to
do three - actually juggle right I don't
have a truck you gotta juggle
Phil I know how to juggle the universe
but coconuts nope
okay court looking for a job I'll work
for free and start off doing anything
even cleaning toilets Gary Vee I promise
to be an asset all right Courtney
vaynermedia looking for a job I work for
free and start off doing anything even
clean cleaning toilets Gary Vee I
promise to be an asset Courtney you've
got a meeting
show me I put up my two fingers for them
to think of screenshot do you see this
yes everywhere oh my god look at this
I'm gonna go back on Facebook live
excuse me Instagram live but I'm not
gonna say a word I'm just gonna do that
I want to see how many people know what
those
good
[Music]
[Music]
all right I can't do that only cuz the
1,500 people I can't assume they were in
the last stream and I feel like a dick
anyway I don't know if you guys saw this
earlier but it's crazy if you go look at
people that tagged me on it's real can
you see can other people see that view
cuz that's my view of people tagged wait
you going to serve anyway earlier today
I just want to give a big shout out to
everybody that was part of my earlier
stream where I said put this up it's so
sad that I that I didn't go to uh you
can you go to my account you can see it
other people tagged so check this out if
you go to my account after this go to my
account and then see the little part
where you can see we're your tagged and
I guess you can see it on my account and
see where I was tagged so many of you of
the 2600 of you tagged the photo of me
doing this so you screenshot this and
then you guys left comments in your then
you post it on your Instagram and you
tagged me and then you said you know why
you follow me and thinks that nature and
obviously people didn't have any stories
to and use the I carry bee and I just
want to say thank you that was amazing
the earlier you know what's sad about
Instagram live is it doesn't record or
save to your camera roll and so d-roc
wasn't there that was my fault and I
went crazy how many people were part of
the last session just say part of it so
other people can see it was crazy
because I was so fired up about this
obviously this last week last ten days
have been a remarkable virality for me
so many of you actually how many of you
in here are new in the last two weeks
also put that I'm curious but I think
it's just been a it's been crazy
the momentum enormous growth here on
Instagram obviously the new features
have worked out the sixty second Club
has worked out the videos have been
fired oh do you rock what about that
minute 10 second video that I made
yesterday yeah they've got it ready like
I love it
anyway just wanted to say thank you the
new call-in show the askgaryvee callin
show the new format i hope you've
checked that out go check it up in
youtube and facebook but most of all
just want to thank everybody
because basically the whole conversation
was king newbie look at all these
newbies we'll press new sport J a new
DeSean Boyd new love it the part of it
part of it love it I never miss you to
Kobe anyway I just I was basically going
crazy earlier this morning and did this
thing because I wanted people to share
because I was explaining what I want to
accomplish here which is I'm on a
mission and I mean a real mission to
change the current narrative of people
that are trying to change their lives
get motivated and then start their
businesses and and become successful and
I want to make it a practical
conversation and I want to destroy and I
mean destroy all these people that are
bottom feeding and genuinely doing the
wrong thing by creating content and
selling it to you guys $300 ebooks
courses you know yes sir
me me like in life not a whole whole lot
yeah we'll figure something out cool
I'll come back anyway I just wanted to
create clarity because there's so many
new people in here and really I wanted
to get people to understand why I'm so
desperate to continue to build my
audience because I basically want every
single person on earth to pay attention
to what I have to say because I'm very
confident of two things one for me I
know that I'm not asking for your money
I went in this great ran the Iraq I
can't force it now so it's it's a lost
moment but I was like I don't want your
money I was like I don't want your money
I want you to keep your money in your
pocket I just want your attention so I
can show you what to do so you don't go
and spend on these [ __ ] things so
you do understand there's no shortcuts
so you like it was just like I want to
keep your [ __ ] money in their pocket
you know like and so I'm just trying to
set the course trying to set the course
and so try and get people to pass me on
because there's people bottom-feeding
there's people doing the wrong thing
there's people that don't have the right
intent and they're and they're taking
advantage of people when they're in a
sad place or when they're nervous or
insecure and so automobile exotica
there's a shout out those house what's
up baby I want to make people to know
that uh that um I'm focused I'm focused
on getting all all the attention I love
you back and all of the attention so I
can do a couple of things number one my
number one goal for all 2,700 2,800 of
you is one first and foremost to build
self-esteem I want all of you to be more
confident tomorrow than you were
yesterday because you're spending time
paying attention to my crap because it's
very simple that my crap speaks to this
stop worrying about what you're not and
start focusing on who you are
we all suck at [ __ ] do you know how
quickly I would be fired if I at Tyler's
job yeah and if the rock had my job I
mean we'd all be fired because that's
not what we're about when you figure out
what you're good at and where your
strengths lie then you will win and I'm
tired of your mom saying you're a loser
or your or your boyfriend saying you
can't or your older brother because he's
insecure not giving you love or self
esteem so that you can succeed I'm tired
of the people closest to you because of
their insecurities and weaknesses giving
you feedback and putting you in a parrot
it in a parrot in a path that keeps you
suppressed because they've got their
insecurities do you know why do you do
you guys know why I don't have a process
of charging you do you know why there's
no rabbit hole for you to give me your
money it's actually quite simple it's
cuz I make my money elsewhere do you
know why I give you my best advice and
why I build you up because I genuinely
think you can't beat me then I think I'm
better that if you fully replicate
everything that I do I will still beat
you because I'm hungrier I can I'm a
machine you know kind of machine do you
know I [ __ ] date do you know I went I
traveled I flew from LA to Atlanta for a
meeting and then flew back on Sunday and
you know how unfazed I was you know I
had some dark under my eyes and daily be
wasn't great and I naturally had them
and I was tired as [ __ ] I'm just I'm
just stronger than you I'm just better
than you and believe it or not that's
not a negative it's what gives me the
ability to give you everything I've got
I'll give you everything I will give you
everything I have I will give you the
best advice if you're really smart
you'll pay attention to what I do and
you can leverage that I will encourage
you I will shoot it to you straight when
you suck some [ __ ] I will do everything
that's in your best interest because if
I do everything in your best interest
you will love me more that's why I have
the best community I don't have the
biggest I'm the biggest I'm the best of
the best because the quality of the 3200
people in this room is higher and I'll
tell you why I'll tell you why it's
higher it's higher because the majority
of you have figured out why I'm
different than the rest of the market
you've figured it out you've figured out
you have figured out you guys have
figured out that I'm different that my
my hey Rupert root root i what am i
doing I'm going to film and then him yep
cool good to see you brother how's your
flight
cool man I'll see you probably like 30
25 we'll have to move around right I'm
just telling my community why I'm giving
him the best content in the world that's
it I'm just better than everybody else
and that allows me to give it to you
more a better and cleaner and you'll
wait for the other shoe to drop and
cynicism will prevail and you'll be
confused by others and a lot of you are
following people that aren't bringing
value but they're selling you what you
want to hear I'm selling you what you
don't want to hear I'm selling you it's
gonna take a long time that you have to
figure out your skills that it's hard
then that it's a grind that it's not
attractive that you might not be doing
it the right way I'm telling you that
all of you might not be talented enough
I'm telling you the hard stuff so you
guys like me aka give me your attention
which I'm so thankful for and I will
never take for granted and the reason
gage with you guys is because I'm so
thankful and so all my friends asked me
why I waste my time being garyvee
because they recognize that they
recognize that I can make more money not
spending time like there's a lot of
money making I could do in this 17
minutes that I'm doing right here what
they don't realize is I've already made
enough money meaning of course I want to
buy the Jets but love and community is
the greatest it's the craziest feeling
of my life the craziest I'm coming the
craziest feeling of my life and I
appreciate you guys and I will always
give you my best and forever
it's time that you guys start really
paying attention
I implore you guys to really pay
attention to who dave sweet home says
jet still suck - that's alright they've
let me say Dave sweet this is where
people this is where I get a little
gangster Dave sweet home says jet still
suck though I'm clicking on his face
hide live from Dave boom see you Dave
deep no longer can see your live streams
sorry Dave hope you continue to consume
my content on regular Instagram anyway
the one place I'm emotional and not
practical is the Jets don't [ __ ] with my
Jets I will hang up on your ass like you
saw on dailyvee and I will block you I
by the way game is the first tune being
I've ever blocked people have come on
said I'm a scam artist I'm the worst
[ __ ] you you've seen in the comments no
block I never hide any of my comments
you said they just suck [ __ ] out
anyway love you guys I have a great day
I will talk to you soon and I appreciate
your attention I will never take it for
granted
and I wish you super duper duper well oh
Kaplan PUD let me just put up cut putt I
don't have to go to this meeting but
there's pod pin let's guy right here
Phil Kaplan beast internet beast
internet beast please
wait what so so help me understand this
what do you want to do because I think
you right now you're looking for money
which I love because cash is oxygen and
I appreciate that
now do you live at home good so what I'm
trying to figure out is like how grimy
you can be meaning I want to I want to
give you the most patients that you can
you know that's the big thing right you
know you know about my self-awareness
thing and that's awesome because that's
good how about the patience thing like
are you buying into my patience thing or
is that like hard to think about eating
[ __ ] until you're 27 for the next seven
years of your life before yourself
self-awareness I think the best thing to
happen is for you to use your
self-awareness about you to become
successful so that you have something to
stand on when you talk about
self-awareness and or you have to go and
get you know a degree and sit on the
back of psychology and and that whole
you know world those are your only two
options because nobody's gonna give a
[ __ ] about your opinion on
self-awareness as a twenty to twenty
year old just saying I like
self-awareness they're just not gonna
care you know no takers will take your
opinion now there's a what's that
who the [ __ ] are you talking to I mean I
know and or you deployed that skillset
for you to be successful and then you
attributed to that you documented that
and then you sold on that I think you
should spend the next month or two
thinking about the things you love the
most music food fashion art I don't care
and that you should find something to
sell and then use your CPA skills your
social skills your selling skills and
try to build something you sell
sell something keep it and or spend it
on the initial inventory of the products
you need to sell all right I gotta go
I'm filming something I hate the guy I
mean I've gone way over I'm like
enjoying this conversation listen to me
you're 20 do you know that if you lived
an entire another life like you died
right now and became alive again and
lived your whole life you'd still be one
year younger than me I need you to think
about that because you will because I
need you to understand one thing if you
decide to give me any more of your
attention all I want you to hear is one
word patience go work for your cousin
and make nine dollars an hour in
painting or 14 or whatever the [ __ ] he's
gonna pay pay you because you respect
him trust him and he's been successful
and what you're doing is you're getting
paid to observe his behavior good
because fast we can nip with friends
we've never crossed that line
I saw your eyes BoBoiBoy it's got me
wondering
so grab your tray let's run away where
we can be oh I think I just made confess
my true feelings
I find this fellow feeling
the zone bug dude let's go give me one
of those yeah
[Music]
we drink this whole bottle we'll pretend
we don't recall that's why we're living
with a living you know
you know same sneakers today somebody
sent us the same thing I mean I didn't
know of you before of course I get it I
get it I started to follow you in the
videos I feel like also coming from
nothing and working when you see someone
who's passionate about their IQ and
wants it for everybody else you know
really that this is so authentic this is
so authentic that's what works to your
point if I do this there's gonna be no
if I sell again you know what I really
need from you for my own [ __ ] like
ego and competitive juices and you gave
it to me when I need you no you're
obviously try it you want to make this
deal happen I'm telling you this is
gonna only fall apart if something crazy
happens yeah I want you know and I don't
mean just but I know what matters for
you but like what would the market be
like how the [ __ ] did they sell that
much what is that do you know yeah okay
I'll see you guys later
yeah and we're taking a separate course
this is easier okay so I'll see you at
the airport see you later
goodnight the meanings I don't know what
did you get today secret meetings
little face time just listen I mean I'm
working here like that's what I have to
say
[Music]
if we drink this whole bottle we'll
pretend we don't recall that's a good
excuse
[Music]